well the thesis in my book is very
straightforward that is energy
independence is neither doable nor
desirable the u.s. is too big of an
energy consumer where the single largest
energy consumer in the world the idea
that we can divorce ourselves from the
world single biggest business which is
the global energy sector five trillion
dollar a year business is ludicrous on
its face we need to get rid of this idea
of energy independence and adjust our
rhetoric and adjust our sights to the to
the realization that we are
interdependent we have been energy
interdependent interdependent for
decades a quick statistic in 1913 the US
was a net crude oil importer we've been
importing crude from other countries and
been a net crude oil importer for nearly
a century in that century that sir
lapsed since nineteen thirteen we've
only been a net crude oil exporter a
handful of times in a handful of years
we were net crude oil importer for much
of world war two in 2005 we imported
crude oil from 41 countries we imported
gasoline from 46 and jet fuel from 26
it's an interdependent market in
everything from gasoline and jet fuel to
ipods and fresh flowers get used to it
the downside is that we're sending a lot
of our money offshore there's no
question that that economically is
something that that is not the best
thing for our economy how do we deal
with that well I think what we have to
do is take stock of what our advantages
are they the Saudis are not the biggest
supplier of crude to the US or oil
products Canada is we need to embrace
the idea that we are in fact part of the
global market when it comes to energy
we're part of the global market when it
comes to a whole lot of mineral
commodities what we have to do to stay
competitive is realize we're not going
to compete with the Saudis and on the
price of oil they're always going to be
able to produce a cheaper what can we
produce and produce well and therefore
compete in the world market well I think
it's information technology it's farm
products it's airplanes it's you know
cowboy boots you know whatever the
commodity is some electronics we have a
lot of innovation that we can do and a
lot of manufacturing that we can do in
the u.s. do we do better than anyone
else we have to focus on our strengths
and quit worrying about the fact that we
import certain mineral commodities or
whatever get over it it's a global
economy that's not going to change there
is no environment argument for energy
independence and I mean that very very
just that there is no environmental
argument for energy independence if the
US were to attempt energy independence
it would require massive amounts of
refining of coal into into liquid fuels
that is an enormously dirty process
there is scarcely a dirtier process in
terms of co2 production than turning
coal into liquid fuel you know the
environmental impacts would involve huge
amounts of uranium mining the US imports
more than eighty percent of its uranium
we would have to create uranium mines
huge uranium Mills the environmental
impact of truant for the u.s. to tempt
energy independence would be enormous
and would be a huge mistake ethanol has
nothing to do with energy independence
ethanol has everything to do with
scamming the American taxpayer this is
one of the longest-running robberies of
American taxpayers in this country's
history it is a
hijacking of American energy policy by a
small delegates small delegation in
Congress from the farm states that is
allowing them to use this idea of energy
security and talking about energy
independence in order to provide huge
subsidies to ethanol distilleries and to
corn farmers in the farm States that's
all it is it has nothing to do with
valid energy policy it is all about
subsidies and keeping the subsidy
machine rolling well the coals for
energy independence are not new the US
has been since 1970 for Richard Nixon
talked about energy independence in 1974
in the wake of the Arab oil embargo he
promised energy independence by 1980
Gerald Ford promised in 1975 that the US
would be energy independent in ten years
in the late 70s Jimmy Carter talked
about the looming crisis of energy and
called it the moral equivalent of war
this is not new rhetoric what is new is
in the wake of sep tember 11th we had a
very small group but a small but
influential group of people who are big
supporters of the second iraq war also
began talking about this idea of energy
independence and by successfully
conflated of oil and terrorism they have
created this artificial argument that
says oh if we were only energy of an
independent than the US would be more
secure our we wouldn't have to be in the
Persian Gulf that it would be better for
the environment etc etc and so it is
really this small group of some of them
are neoconservatives james Woolsey the
former director of the CIA Frank Gaffney
who was the director of the Center for
security policy in Washington and I
think most prominently probably Thomas
Friedman the columnist for The New York
Times Friedman has written repeatedly
saying that we need to be energy
independent and that the US in fact
needs to build is his words a wall of
energy independence around itself well
how that squares with Friedman's other
thesis that the world is flat makes no
sense at all to me but nevertheless
Friedman has been leading this charge
claiming that if only we bought less oil
or we were able to crush the price of
oil that the Arab and Islamic world's
would reform and that we'd all be
singing Kumbaya I guess
the fact is that there there's no Ruth
to that argument and this but i think
that the successful conflation of oil
and terrorism has been the key argument
that they have put forward and it's been
adopted by the left and the right the
Republicans the Democrats and that has
become a mantra now look we've had
terrorism since before we started using
oil will have terrorism long after the
last drop of oil is is consumed
terrorism does not depend on oil parent
terrorism does not depend on the petro
states which is the argument that is
continually put forward by by frank
gaffney and james Woolsey and Thomas
Friedman that if only we put the petro
States out of business there would be no
terrorism look there was no there was no
petrol dollars involved in the sep
tember eleventh attack the attack cost
less than five hundred thousand dollars
according to the 911 Commission there
were no petrol dollars involved in the
Madrid train bombings or the London bus
bombings Timoth Timothy McVeigh in bham
the Oklahoma City the Murrah Building in
Oklahoma City there's no connection with
petrodollars the irish republican army
used terrorism for decades there was no
connection with petrol dollars this idea
that terrorism depends on on oil is
foolishness well a terrorism is a very
low-tech and low-cost operation it is
funded largely by drugs by organized
crime by the weapons trade by human
trafficking any number of things the
this idea this conflation of oil and
terrorism is a convenient one but it's a
false connection